Guys, futbol may BE the biggest thing going
on right now on EARTH.
But what about in Space?
Do they get to see the matches too?
Hey world, Trace here for DNews and this is
our Weekly Space Update!
You can be sure the astronauts flying on the
ISS are trained both physically and mentally
for their journey.
They are required to exercise daily, and run
experiments, perform spacewalks and fulfill
duties at all hours of the day... but NASA
ensures they're not just worker bees, but
that they take care of their psychological
needs as well.
They have a way to uplink movies that aren't
already up there, but what about for other
things... like...the Super bowl, Olympics,
World Cup, US Open, the World Chess Championship
-- Dude, Magnus Carlsen is defending his title
this year!!!
AAHH!! // *cut mid-freakout*
Everyone in the world, and some people in
the United States are going balls-on-the-pitch
crazy about the largest, most-watched sporting
event on the planet, the World Cup.
And seeing as this is the INTERNATIONAL space
station, we've probably got some fútbol loving
astronauts!
So, NASA's Johnson Space Center is on the
case to make sure these intrepid explorers
get their psychological needs met!
A NASA representative told us, "the final
match of the World Cup falls during off-duty
time on a Sunday, so they might choose to
watch some of the game live."
So they DO get to watch it.
Another press release showed astronauts enjoying
a ten minute highlight reel earlier this week.
So they are definitely up on the biggest sports
Earth news this week.
But technology isn't magic.
They can't just swipe a TV show up into the
clouds and have it fly to the space station!
The ISS has to have Ku-Band connection with
mission control.
It's called the Ku because it's directly below
the K-band on the electromagnetic spectrum;
Ku...
K-Under... get it?
The 12-18 gigahertz Ku band isn't just for
sending "Fast n' Loud" marathons to the ISS,
it's also used for satellite communications
and television broadcasting.
The ISS uses the Ku because it has a higher
bandwidth than their normal internet uplink,
so it's ideal for sending large amounts of
information, like a live broadcast.
Johnson Space Center has a special license
from their satellite cable company to re-direct
channels that astronauts want to see directly
to the station.
Like cell phone service on the ground, the
Ku coverage in space varies, but the ISS is
usually able to connect to Johnson Space Center
for 80 minutes during each 90 minute orbit.
That's a long 10 minute blackout during an
exciting sportsball match, but if they're
not streaming something live they can use
it for other things too.
So let's just say, for kicks, that no one
was interested in the World Cup.
Astronauts don't just sit around watching
the tube, they also can use their computers
to surf the web, or call home.
THey play musical instruments, read and so
on.
These are all "important aspects of psychological
support for astronauts on long-duration missions."
That's according to our friendly NASA representative.
They can even watch movies together in their...
*snicker* makeshift Movie Theatre.
In fact, according to NASA there's a growing
collection of DVDs brought up by past missions.
Watching the "Star Trek" series was a weekly
event for former ISS astronaut Greg Chamitoff.
If you could take three movies with you to
the ISS, which three would you take?
Tell us the movies you'd take in the comments,
and subscribe!
But before you go...
If you're a space-geek who likes to space
out and learn about space...
NEXT Tuesday, June 24 we doing our monthly
Google Hangout with NASA/JPL.
DID you know they don't just look up to the
stars - they also care a lot about good old
terra firma!
We're going to talk with some of the scientists
working on Earth science missions!
It's going to be so great!
Check the description for the link to RSVP,
and get your questions ready!